[Music]
Boo Boo Boo lesle no Boo Here Comes the
boo all dressed and boo boo lesie no boo
boo boo dude what are you doing I'm
being awesome boo boo lesie boo my
friend I don't think you understand what
a bad idea this is I don't think you
understand that I would have got a cut
of that new Punch Burger if she hadn't
screwed everything up so sorry guys this
wedding is cancelled cuz the Bride is a
bee hole hey check this out stink bomb
who knows what that does
oh stink bomb are you joking oh my God
where did you even get a stink bomb
Amazon baby that's how you are looking
at a Prime customer everybody two days
free shipping for this guy let's get
this party started with another one gang
no ah it's terrible Jerry you do the
wedding who cares come on man just go
home now who's going to make me it's
your wedding day I'll handle this here
comes the bride time to go sir no hey
get off me what the hell man don't you
touch me oh I'll give you that one but
if you do it again oh if I do what again
what kick your ass is that what you like
you want me to just
pound yay best wedding
ever falta yo
I looked at the photos of your victim on
your desk is that FR I said hi puncture
wounds are similar to a case I had a
while back they aren't from a knife I
think it's something spiral like a pork
screw don't shush me I'm helping you no
no no I'm holding a baby that was
actually very helpful thank you uhoh you
better get back here
now oh hello
poala oh
no no no I know why you're so upset man
I'm the one had to come into this
Backwater stink hole what's up L man
what's up you feeling sexy huh yeah I
feel sexy yeah you look sexy man you
know I do watch out for that
door yo how much you bench
seriously captain please please pretty
please do not let him take over my case
Major Crimes is stepping in nothing I
can do you're off the case I can't
believe you're just rolling over and
giving my murder away to the vulture we
call him the vulture because he swooped
in and solves cases that are almost
solved and takes a credit for himself
yes boil I put that together from
Context first of all major crimes has
jurisdiction over any and all cases they
want to take but more importantly you're
the one who insisted on working alone I
told you for weeks to use the squad and
you refused I used them I mean Rose is
the one who figured out the cork screw
Charles caught a
dog well congratulations Detective Bo
you should have involved them sooner
turn over your files to detective
pinbrook sir calm the vulture give
giving him a name makes him human turn
over the files fine but in protest I'm
walking over there extremely
slowly thank
you God this is so boring for both of us
hey know before I solve this case I'd
like to thank you for doing all the
super easy work you know the real Nancy
Drew level stuff oh yeah did Nancy Drew
solve a lot of murders yeah she did
murder on Ice recipe for murder Nancy
was a wonderful detective I wanted to be
hurt when I grew up thanks Charles
that's helpful hey should we take odds
on how fast I'll solve this case n i
mean what was it with Diaz's last
impossible extortion case what was it 6
hours that's because it was 98% solved
the last 2% are is again that's why they
leave it in the milk what oh wow looking
good Santiago
good foxy ma go rotten hell this is your
fault thanks champ good effort I got it
from here and hey you feel free to call
me anytime you need me to come down here
and help powder that big white ass of
yours well that's the worst thing that's
ever happened to
me can I sit
here
you know I uh I know a little bit about
what you're going through in a
way um when I was a kid my parents got
divorced they both want a custody and
they both asked me to testify against
the other one in
court so I don't know I didn't want him
to get divorced in the first place you
know I love them both so much
I just
wanted okay so let's get ready for the
photo guys I want you to arrange
yourselves from most excited about
democracy to least excited wait a minute
everybody's excited I bet you are
because your bill just became
[Applause]
lost well you know I can't believe you
traded your office to keep this craphole
pool open for a couple more weeks a year
hey can you not say that in front of the
kids please I'm trying to teach them how
great government is oh this is a
teaching moment
great hey uh kids would you like to
learn how lesli got your bill passed
councilwoman nope traded my vote for
her what the hell man why'd you do that
um um because it's fun in the sun
everybody in the
pool yay
democracy oh no my perm Captain I don't
I don't know if this is too much but I
got deputy chief Bran's little basket of
pears they look ripe and crispy hello
Raymond Captain wch good to see you but
if you're here who's guarding Hades it's
deputy chief watch now unsurprisingly
I've been promoted above you and now I'm
here to evaluate you what happened to
Brand he retired and moved to Charleston
to be closer to his grandchildren so
much for dying at your desk with a
little dignity interesting I will
attempt to cooperate with you under
these new circumstances don't sweet talk
me halt I gave it my best shot
let's
begin Kelly how are you I had have the
longest meeting oh welcome to my
convenience store would you like some
Googy Googy I have some very delicious
Googy googie only 99 cents plus stack
try my Googy Googy try my Googy Googy
try my Googy Googy try
my all right all right
yes that was great she gets it now she
knows what it's like to be a
minority
this rules did you know that my dream
has always been to have my picture taken
with a mountain of recovered cash that's
always been my dream to take that
picture of you Jake oh yeah yeah $21
million Raymond I have to admit I'm
impressed sorry to disappoint you mine I
know you'd H we failed oh no I couldn't
be happier wait why would you say that
and why aren't you clenching your little
red hands in
anger you didn't want me to fail you
wanted me to succeed that's right I was
looking for an excuse to promote you to
a desk job and you handed it to me on a
silver platter with your little rat
hands oh no say goodbye to the 99
Raymond I'm making you head of nypb
public relations Captain get in here
with me go ahead smile for the cameras
Raymond that's your new job
now next order of business it's agenda
item 280b a motion to construct a dog
park on Municipal lot 48 uh Miss Ludgate
you have the floor thank you councilman
Jam your help and general non- awfulness
is much appreciated Leslie members of
the council I believe that Municipal lot
48 should be a dog park I boo well it
sounds like there's considerable
opposition to this so I'm Sorry Miss
late you should go now really I just
heard one hag booing ladies please let's
keep this civil
councilman pans satisfied customers of
jam Orthodontics as we discuss what type
of Park to put on lot 48 I had a
thought how about no Park who here
thinks parks are stupid let the records
show that everyone is raising their
hands I happen to know for a fact that
P's favorite fast food restaurant Ponch
bger needs a new location now seeing as
how the future of lot 48 is open for
debate I move we sell it to poncher for
a nice profit you don't even have to be
Asian to do math that simple you told me
you wanted a dog park uh psych it's not
fair you lied to me you just got jammed
I hate when he say
that